Wherever there's large Muslim
populations, you have a lot of problems.
You have criminality. You have rape. You
have grooming gangs with England. You
have problems in Sweden. You have
problems in Germany, Austria, that's
France. Okay? So, there's a reason for
that. But if you can't understand the
first premise, which is that's the way
it's always been based on Islamic
teaching, then you're always going to
look for some other excuse. You're going
to say, "This is racism. This is Muslim
grievances. This is whatever. They're
disenfranchised. Well, no, because it
was always the case. Even when Islam was
superior and way more powerful than
Europe. That's how it
was. I have a very special guest with me
today. His name is Raymond Ibrahim. And
Raymond is actually I think uh or his
ancestors are Egyptian or his parents
are Egyptian. He's a Middle East
scholar. He's a scholar of the Quran, a
scholar of wars and uh jihad in the
Middle East, primarily in Europe where
they intersect. So I wanted to have him
come on and talk to us about the real
history of the authentic history of
jihad from the very beginning. And we're
going to hit some real highlights, if
you want to call them that. um from the
very beginning with Muhammad and his
poor righteous uh followers, the poor
next khifs all the way up to, you know,
somewhere around today. Thank you for
joining me, Raymond. It's a real
pleasure to have you. Oh, it's my
pleasure, Elizabeth. Uh thanks for
inviting me. Happy to be with you. You
know, we're going to talk about jihad.
And I guess what you should begin with
perhaps is a brief introduction into how
you um got into this topic. You're a
historian and you were working at the uh
Library of
Congress and you began to go through a
whole
uncataloged room of books and they were
all in Arabic and you of course are
fluent in Arabic. and you said, "Okay,
here's my project. I'm going to do
this." And you found some very
interesting things. Tell us about that.
Sure. So, academically, as you indicate,
I majored in history and um I was a
student of Victor Davis Hansen at the
time, who was really focused on military
military history. And so, I really
gravitated to that and that's what I
liked. And you know my very first um my
master's thesis was about the first
battle between Muslims and Christians
the battle of Yarmmu and you know it
came out I think in 2001. Anyway, then I
went to Georgetown University and then I
got a job at the Library of Congress as
you're indicating where I worked with
Arabic, other not Middle Eastern um
language books and uh being a biblopile,
I was like a child in a you know candy
factory because I had access to all
these books and I would spend a lot of
time perusing through them and um yeah,
I came across writing by al-Qaeda, Osama
bin Laden and Aman Zawati. Um, this is
around 2005 when I came across this and
I realized that they had not been
translated. They had not disseminated
and I had also found that they said the
exact opposite of what what uh al-Qaeda
had been saying to the west and which
was being disseminated by Western media
which was basically they were saying we
attacked you 9/11 because you attacked
us. This is you know this is just
retaliation. It's because of Israel.
It's because of colonialism. you know,
it was a non-stop list of grievances.
Okay. But then the writings that I found
in Arabic said the exact opposite. It
became a more theological argument
against the West. And the long and short
of it was basically we have to hate and
attack the West, Americans, etc. on uh
just because they're infidels. Okay. So,
it was more like an ISIS type argument.
All right. And um yeah, long story
short, I translated it. It became a book
was published by Double Day in
2007. And then um from that point on I
title rate reader by the way I highly
recommend it. I have it on my pad as
well as sort of the scimitar and uh it's
I think it's a very very important book
and I think it should be in the library
of anybody who's going to be doing
legislation or discussing anything if
they uh want to be authoritative on what
the the sources or the purpose and the
reason for jihad is. It is not a
defensive war, which is what we always
hear when they go to the Quran. Well,
that that was just defensive and we're
only allowed to attack for defensive
purposes. By the way, side note though
here, do you think that one of the
reasons why um the press, the
establishment press that is obviously
usually anti-Israel and
pro Islam for some reason that they
don't report the truth on the
motivations because they just never hear
them and they don't dig deep enough to
really because I know the motivations
because I listen to them translated from
memor uh by memory in from Arabic into
English. To me, it seems pretty obvious
to most pe that it should be to most
people that these are theological issues
because they hate us because we do not
accept Allah, Muhammad, the Quran, and
their theology or do you think it's um
for other reasons?
No. Um I think your question is that why
does the media not report on it? Is it
intentional or what? Uh at this point
it's absolutely intentional. Uh because
it it's uh my own personal experiences
when I back in 2007 the al-Qaeda came
out al-Qaeda reader came out was invited
on all the mainstream media channels and
um but then when I started saying what I
started saying which is gravitating
towards more and proving that it's more
of a theological and doctrinal thing I
was dropped off immediately. and the
same people I was in contact with, they
didn't want to hear it. They didn't even
want to debate it. Okay, so that's my
own personal experience, but I know this
is just the case in general with even
other people. Um, you know, think about
for one, one of the most obvious ways to
prove this is and you know, okay, so
talk about Israel and Palestine and and
the that conflict for example, it's okay
to talk about Muslims attacking Israel
and um there's it's not hard for the
media to spin it or say whatever it
wants because everyone sees the Muslims
as the underdogs and that's what an
underdog does. He fights back. He even
engages in terrorism. So it becomes
logical. But what do you make of the
fact that all around the Muslim world
where Muslims are dominant, they're
persecuting Christians who are
minorities and who are weak and who have
nothing to do with creating grievances
against Islam. They just want to
practice their religion and peace. And
yet they're being persecuted. So that is
a major story. But the media goes out of
its way, and I know this for a fact,
never to cover it. And if they have to
cover it because of some spectacular
attack, you know, 70 Christians were
found decapitated in the church, then
they start spinning it to the point
where, you know, in Nigeria where
there's a genocide of Christians, the
official narrative by the media and
politicians is this is about climate
change and it has nothing to do with
religion. So they will go out of their
way uh and and I know this for a fact.
um you know in 2015 when uh 20 or 21
Coptic Christians were beheaded by ISIS
in Libya and because they would they
wouldn't recant their faith. um that
obviously they had to cover that but
someone did number crunching and at the
same time the same day the video came
out I think some gorilla called Hamra or
something was killed in America and that
that killing of the gorilla got
something like 10 times the coverage
that 21 outrageous a gorilla a gorilla
dies it must be imperialism or settler
colonialism and
supremacyism yeah so Okay. Yeah, I guess
I think we're pretty much on the same
page. It just seems too intentional.
Um, so your book Sword and
Scimitar, which one of the reasons I
love it is it's so succinct. This is a
real recommendation because I have many,
many books that just are overwhelming.
And when you have little time anymore
and X becomes your history class half
the time, um having a succinct book that
spans history from Muhammad all the way
up, well, I can't remember which battle.
I think it was was it um Constantinople?
I go to the bar the Barbrey Wars. Oh,
we're going to hit the Barbaries. Okay.
So, I just want to read um Victor Davis
Hansen does the introduction or the
forward to this book. um obviously at
the Hoover Institute um at Stanford and
I just wanted to
read the last paragraph. Sword and
Scimitar is first rate military history
and a product of solid scholarship and
filiological research. It
characteristically offers candid
appraisal of a rivalry that has now
taken on quite different incarnations
and played out on different fronts from
contemporary immigration to terrorism
but still in many ways remains an
ancient existential struggle
nonetheless. Um I read that because
firstly is uh jihad has many forms and I
want to hit on that as we're having our
conversations which is exactly what he
was saying right here. But what he
points out is this is an ancient
existential struggle. It by
existential who's going to exist when
the struggle is all over. Now we're both
Christians. We know how the story ends.
But there's a lot of people that can be
hurt. Nations can be brought down. Um,
culture is destroyed in the meantime.
And we're supposed to fight the good
fight nonetheless. So let's get started
uh
with let's just start from the beginning
with Muhammad and how you would portray
the um militaristic jihadist
um and maybe even imperialistic
uh desires of Muhammad because I'm not
quite sure from the Quran how much it
how explicit it is that they have to
move out from the the Arab Ian Peninsula
and sweep across the world as they did.
Yeah. So, as you indicated, it all
starts with Muhammad, of course, and um
his particular teachings. I'm mostly
interested in the barebone background of
Muhammad. You know, some people obsess
about him and everything he said and did
and some tell you he doesn't exist. But
the barebone teachings is and we have a
lot of records for this is basically he
was a militant warlord who said he is a
prophet and he promised paradise to his
followers. And some people at the time,
you know, we have records of people
calling him a false prophet and others
following him. But the long and short of
it is, you know, a lot of the more his
his attacks grew on non-Muslims and, you
know, the plunder and the booty that
came with it, the more his following
grew um until it b essentially he
consolidated all of Arabia under the
standard standard of Islam. And um he
dies in 632 and now you know all these
Arab tribes that were once fighting each
other are one group. They're the
Muslims, the Muslims, the believers and
the khalifs, the the rashidun that you
mentioned, the first khalifs. They now
launched them out to start conquering
the nations uh surrounding them. And um
it you know where where this teaching
comes from. Later on of course you get
the Quran compilations and you get
hadith sir and so for modern day Muslims
it all traces back to what we would call
Islamic law Sharia uh which is based on
specifically the Quran and the hadith.
And if you look at those and you read
them it's more so the hadith but it's in
the Quran as well. Um it's very it comes
down to the succinct view that jihad is
armed struggle against the infidel to
bring them under the authority of Islam
until Islam essentially governs the
entire world. Um it's not as some people
would say that you have to force the
whole world to become Muslim. If you're
a Christian and a Jew, you can live as
what's called the dimmi secondass
citizen and you pay tribute etc. And um
but if you're not, you know, according
to the literal teaching, you have to be
slaughtered. And so that's why uh
apparently more Hindus than any other
non-Muslims were butchered through the
centuries. Well, I think hundreds of
millions is the number. Um but even
then, you know, that the law essentially
changed. It was better to just tax them
and make money killing them. Anyway, so
this is enshrined in Islamic teaching.
It's a well-known aspect. It's jihad and
it blows up all around the world. Now,
most people don't realize Wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a
minute, wait a minute, wait a minute. I
slow down.
We got a couple minutes. I I want to I
want to push back on one thing and I
want to clarify a few others.
Um Muhammad brought the Arabian
Peninsula under uh Islamic rule though
by the sword. It wasn't that he gave
them an opportunity the his fellow Arabs
to live as demies, did he? Because I
never really saw that. Obviously
slaughtered Christians. He obviously
slaughtered Jews and his dying wish was
that uh this the Arabian Peninsula
should be free of all Jews and all
Christians forever which did happen. I
think his second successor or first or
second made that happen. But this is my
question. Was there any demi status
offered to the pagan Arabs in the the uh
peninsula?
Well, if you look at Muhammad's career
and how it developed, it's actually
according to Islamic teaching, standard
mainstream Sunni teaching, it goes in
essentially three phases. And the first
phase is when he was weak and
outnumbered and living in Mecca. And
this is when he actually preached peace
and tolerance and uh and not arm
struggle. And these are the they're
known as the Mecca verses. And this is
why a lot of the apologists, this is
what they get away with. They cite and
cherrypick the Meccan verses which say
things like, "You have your religion, I
have mine." And it sounds good. Okay.
Then at one point in well 622 year one
of the higra or or the Islamic calendar
he flees to Medina and um now he starts
becoming growing in power and then the
message starts shifting to now you can
fight them back if they attack you. But
then he continues growing in power and
consolidating and more more more and
more people submit to his political
authority becoming Muslims and now the
final stage comes out which is now you
have to go on the armed offensive. This
is the classic definition of jihad. And
um so these are these latter verses are
recorded are referred to as the Medinan
verses. So if you look at the Quran, you
know, you have the Meccan verses which
are older and you have the Medina verses
even though they're kind of mixed
together. It's not it's not written in a
chronological. It's not ordered that
way. So it gets a little confusing. So
for Christians uh and Jews and and
anybody else who reads the scriptures,
the Bible, and then looks at the Quran,
I want to point something very very
quickly out that when they ordered the
Quran, they did something that I've
never heard in my entire life. Maybe I
don't know, I've never heard that the
this the chapters, if you will, are
organized the longest to the shortest.
And so the that so it's very easy to be
deceptive when you're in a Muslim
apologist because you so nobody really
knows here's the mechan passages that
were at the beginning of his uh mission
if you will and then here are the Medina
and so you have to go by what Muslim
scholars and later other scholars say as
the order of um or the separation
between the Medan and Mecc and so like
you said you have my religion I have my
religion that's gone 920 chapter 9 is
really important chapter I would say in
describing what the final
uh theology or or political theology of
Muhammad was and that is what do you
want to right yeah so what you're
referring to is also known in Islamic
law in Arabic as an
which means abrogation. And so basically
in Islamic teaching the old if there's a
contradiction and there are in the Quran
the later the newer verse that came out
the Medinian verses takes precedence.
Okay. So which which means that as you
mentioned you know surah Toba chapter 9
that's the most militant one. It's the
Medinian ones and it has two of what's
called the the two sword verses. One is
uh 95 and the other is 929. and just
taken together they declare allout jihad
on everyone including Christians and
Jews and um according to Islamic exits
those two verses have abregated
something like 120 peaceful verses but
there's also yeah but there's also
another interesting element to it other
Muslims say and this makes perfect sense
they say we because Muslims follow the
example of Muhammad that's what the word
Sunni means example and they say so we
can actually follow the verses that
apply to us including We can give
precedence to the Meccan verses which
are peaceful over the Medinian ones if
we are in the same situation. So what
they mean by that is if I'm a Muslim and
I'm living as an outnumbered minority
amongst infidels in a western nation, I
should preach peace, okay, as a sort of
strategm. I shouldn't obviously declare
jihad because I'm going to get myself
killed or throw in jail and it's totally
ineffective and it's just going to make
Islam look bad. So, so Muslims believe
they can use these verses depending on
their own circumstances and match the
life of Muhammad. And I'll just share
with you one very telling anecdote that
occurred when I was at the Library of
Congress. There were many Muslims that
worked there. And one of them I was very
friendly with and we would always um you
know speak uh we would talk about these
topics. We would I would challenge him.
We'd have like you know like a
interfaith dialogue sort of thing, but
it was it was kind of in a bantering
friendly way. And I mentioned this whole
thing to him and uh you know at first he
see he he tried to act ignorant. He was
talking about the Meccan verses and just
telling me no but man it's all about
peace. You see there's this there's this
and I broke down what I just said to you
and I said well wait you know this is
Mecca and then Muhammad when he moves on
and it becomes Medina this and
that. He finally got frustrated goes
well what do you want from me? I'm
living in Mecca. So his point is oh that
is hysterical. That is a great little
anecdote. I love that. Uh because we we
know anyone who I I can't imagine how
all Americans don't know this by now.
And I think that there is sort of some
kind of a tipping point. I don't know
when it began or if it's yet to begin
where most Americans will understand the
things like
kudabia takia you know all all you know
the mechan versus abrogation it's talked
about so much and this is why it's
important to just keep talking about it
so this is a form of tea tea and and
this is the permission given by Muhammad
to
lie. He lists three items. One is lie to
your wife if it makes her feel better
about something and lie to uh in war.
War is deception, right? Deception.
Yeah. He's I don't know if you read uh
the art of war if you had an
air the art of war, but and I can't
remember the third item. um that he said
you Yeah, you can lie to two you can lie
to two quarreling parties to reconcile
them. Okay. Yeah, there you go. So this
um Muslims consider themselves to be in
when they're in the West, they are still
in a state of war. It's just a different
kind of holy war. Um I advocate that we
use the term jihad instead of terrorist
all the time.
I advocate that we actually use the
words that identify them uh identify the
reality more specifically instead of
saying you know extremists or radicals
or terrorists that we talk about
jihadists and Shariaists I I call them
as well.
Uh the one push back I had for you um
I've trained myself to never say the
words secondass citizens because uh
demies are not secondass and they are
not citizens. What they are are a
despised minority. Uh even if when
they're in the majority they're in the
minority. They they do not rule and they
are subjugates and they have essentially
only the rights that a capriccious ruler
will allow them to have and they are in
total submission unlike
um I don't know probably like some other
societies in history go to ancient Japan
ancient China and other places but this
is this is carrying that kind of
subjugation into to the modern world.
And so I just essentially say they're
despised minority uh subjected to all
Muslims of all not just leaders but all
Muslims within the under which they are
find themselves u uh subject subjugated.
Uh that's not a very shorthand way of
saying it. You can you can shorten that.
Uh but do you agree that they're not
really second hand secondass citizens?
are more like third and fourth almost
closer to a a slave.
I do agree with that and in fact if you
look at some of my older videos I would
say third class citizens but then I had
people ask me like what do you mean by
that and technically means this. So what
you just said I do agree with and um you
know secondass citizen it depends on the
context what one means but yes despised
minority who are barely tolerated and
live according to the tra priests of the
rulers is pretty accurate and also the
the constant uprising of Muslims even if
the ruler is kind towards him um often
times Muslims would just rise up against
him and then the the the ruler would of
course you know turn a blind eye because
it's easier for him to you know let the
Muslims have their own way because
they're the majority. And you know this
this continues paralleling modern day if
you look at Egypt uh some of the stuff
that happens you know they uh a Coptic
man you know whatever uh eloped with a
Muslim woman all of a sudden an entire
city is destroyed or village of
Christians is attacked and the Basilica
of St. Mark right yeah and um or attacks
on churches because some cops met in a
house and tried to pray. I only mention
those because if you actually look at
the history and there's a great book
that came out a few years ago. It's
called The Sword Over the Nile by Adel
Gindi and it's basically based on the
primary sources of the Egyptian
chronicles uh during the Islamic
conquest and thereafter like every
century basically from the entry of
Islam till the modern era and you see
the same exact parallels of what I just
described happening today happening
then. Um, okay. So, yeah. So, a VIMI,
you know, I often just use the words.
I'm trying to make it as simple as
possible for, you know, Americans who
don't understand the subtle
technicalities of Islamic terminology,
but a VIMI is is not a secondass
citizen. Definitely much worse and along
the lines that you mentioned. So, let's
move out of the Arabian Peninsula.
Suddenly, it's what
7:32 62. Well, 63 I we were going to get
to battle of tours in a minute. 632 is
that when Muhammad
died. Okay. Then the then the first
Khalif was that Ali or was that Abu
Bakr? Abu Bakr Bakar. And so he and his
armies uh move out of the Arabian
Peninsula. Tell us what happens next.
Well actually Abu Bakr's reign is only
two years and he also actually he when
Muhammad dies a lot of the Arabian
tribes that had come under his tutelage
break away and actually Muhamm Abu Bakr
the first Khalif reign short reign um is
typified by what's called the Ridda wars
which is these wars against the apostate
Arab tribes because they had tried to
break away from Islam and he brought
them back in through a much bloodshed so
it's really under uh the second khif
Falmer uh who range from uh I want to
say 634 to 7 I'm sorry 634
um to
643 or or something about 10 years and
um that's when really the great Arab
conquests begin and they spread out and
they go and attack greater Syria which
encompassed of course all the modern day
states of Israel, Lebanon, Jordan etc.
Uh that's it's referred to the sources
really as greater Syria and in Egypt as
well. So Egypt gets conquered by 641,
Syria is conquered in 636 very very
quickly and then after that you know
they fall like dominoes. Um uh but I
think the the the part that a lot of
westerners miss is um and this I I only
say this because it comes out a lot but
I don't think most people understand or
have an idea of how Christian that
region was at the dawn of Islam. um you
know you you probably know what I mean
but a lot of Westerners you know when I
about let's say uh oh like the
Christians of the Middle East today
being persecuted they'll say yeah we
sympathize but why would they go and
live
there of course is a reflection of how
they have no idea that area is the
oldest history and that's what this is
why the the purpose of these kinds of
conversations
because it was the the the eastern
empire. Well, the Eastern Roman Empire,
Eastern Christendom was the vast
majority of Christendom time, wasn't it?
Yeah. At the time of that we're just
we're talking about 630s or whatever.
Um, if you talked about Christendom,
it's in precisely the countries that
we're talking about. It was greater
Syria, Egypt, Asia Minor, Anatolia. This
is why Constantine moved the capital
Rome to Constantinople or Nova Roma, New
Rome, which is in
Turkey essentially uh because
Christianity was really and it it was in
Europe as well southwest of the D of the
Ryan and Danube but it was really
entrenched more in the countries that we
today call the Muslim world and North
Africa and uh the Middle East. So you
had five major
sanctialistic and it is colonial. So
when we hear today about settler
colonialism and you know the the reason
for all the poverty and the wars and
everything, it's because of what the
white European males did and their
settler colonialism and the Jews. Let's
just keep in mind this. Firstly, that's
a bunch of garbage. But the Islam
conquered all of Eastern
Christendom and they did it by force.
And so it is an
imperialistic colonial
um
jihadist ideology and religion. And so
whoever is left
uh standing still, the cops in Egypt,
the the Assyrian Christians, um etc.,
etc. Jews are are only there, I mean,
they're there because that was their
home and
Islam through suppression and the force
of Sharia law and violence made it
Islam, made it Islamic. So it is not
indigenously, if you want to use that
term, Islamic, which they actually I
think most people out at
Colombia, you know, those students think
that Islam has the right to
all of those all of the land, the dirt.
Go over pick up the dirt at any place in
the Middle East and North Africa and
this is Muslim dirt. That's their soil.
Yeah. Yeah. It's even worse than that.
It's just, you know, if you ask, and
this is what I was sort of alluding to
earlier, you talk to your average
westerner, they just have no clue that
Muslim lands were formerly Christian
lands. And this is by design because if
they were Christian lands originally, it
means there was conquest and
colonization enforcement of the Islamic
identity in the Arabic language. Um, so
yeah, and you know, you mentioned
colonization and you mentioned conquest
and you but you also forgot slavery,
which is another of the white man's
sins, but it was actually really
perfected by these Arab caliphates at
the time. And you know if you look at
some of the sources of the early years
um it looks like mass slave trade going
on especially for example of the Berbers
in North Africa in the seventh century
where it talks about tens and thousands
of them being chained at all until they
became Muslims and they became the front
line of the Islamic jihad and so forth.
Uh but yeah so that is the the the
conquest. Um and it wasn't just Eastern
Christendom if you look at the map. was
literally 3/4 of the Christian world was
swallowed up because we're talking of
all of North Africa, all of the Middle
East, Spain, okay? And you know, deep
into part of which which is a huge
peninsula, part of France, all of the
Mediterranean islands, all of these were
of course Christian for centuries. Um,
and they got some of them were, you
know, Spain of course went through the
Rakista, so it was 800 years of Islam
and jihad, etc. And I want to get to
Spain in a minute because I want to talk
about a reconista for Europe's in
Europeans in the future if they ever
have the guts to do something about the
war that they've been fighting and
sleeping through at the same time. you
know, um, when we talk about the slave
trade, I think it's worth going in just
another minute or two that the West
African slave trade the and and then the
white slavery, which is essentially
Muslims going into Europe, even over to
Iceland. I don't know if they ever got
to Greenland. It's an important place
today, but up to Iceland and and and
there would be farmers in the fields in
Great
Britain and they and ships would land
and Muslims would come ashore and take
women, children, adults, men and take
them back to North Africa and sell them
as slaves and sex slaves. And this
happened to the tune of millions. I
mean, I think that there's at least a
minimum of four 4 and a half million
white slaves because during I don't know
what was the what the period of time
was. Well, the period of time is from
the dawn of Islam and all the way until
it gets abolished really by Western
European colonial powers. Um, but the
numbers for example, we know like in the
1500s during this time when Iceland was
being attacked, there were about 1.25 25
million slaves in Barbary or B Africa.
And this is to say nothing about the
really large slave trades, the Ottomans
who had um so you know we're talking
about the conquest of Christian
territory threequarters um and I
mentioned Spain, North Africa, the
Middle East, but then we forget as time
progressed now Fijia Miter, one of the
most ancient Christian regions becomes
Turkey and the Balkans get altered. They
also are temp like Spain. They too are
temporarily conquered um under Islam and
experience the same sorts of abuses and
and enslavement. You know the word slave
comes from the word Slav because the
Slavic peoples were so enslaved by the
Ottomans and the Crime Tatars also
Muslim. Um and those sources talk about
again many millions during this time and
that's why the word Slav to be a Slav
was to be a slave. Um, and so the word
slaves
black people, it's white people, right?
And here we're jumping to and and I'm
just making this note for people who are
listening and haven't yet memorized
their jihad timeline. We're talking
about the Ottoman Empire, the Turks, uh,
Muslims, uh, began essentially
around
14 trying to think, back 1400, 1450. I'm
not sure exactly the exact date, but um,
and they had also this other kind of
slavery, which was particularly heinous
when you think about it.
Um well, first I want to mention the
fact that we get the word balkcanization
to describe a region that is literally
always in ethnic, religious, cultural
strife, war, genocides, just you know
violence ongoing because of differences.
How did balkanization arise? Well, when
you take orally I when you take a
Christian region because we're talking
Europe here and then you enslave it
under Islam and you either force or you
have much um many Muslims that either
move into the area colonially or um
others convert uh by the sword or
otherwise. Now you've you've just baked
in ongoing centuries long ethnic,
cultural, religious strife. So that's
bulcanization. But Dev Shereim or Dev
Shereé um and I it's hard for me to
pronounce that word uh frequently, but
that was a particularly heinous thing.
We're still in the Ottoman Empire. So
we're after the 1400s.
um they would actually take tribute in
the form of forcing families in I think
is pretty much Greece, but you can
correct me there, to um to give up their
most beautiful, intelligent
um most athletic little boys to be
hauled off and converted to Islam and
put into the military. So tell us a
little bit about that and and correct my
pronunciation of dev dev sher. Yeah, the
dev sher is basically it was this um and
and I hope I don't forget but after I
tell you what it is I want to tell you
what modern academic western people
portray it as. Um but basically it was
this institute by the Ottomans which was
if you're a subject and it was
essentially just against Christians
because we're talking about Eastern
Europe. This is where it develops. Um,
so they were all Christian subjects and
the the Ottomans would send their men to
these uh tributaries who've been, you
know, broken down and defeated and other
subjects,
their would demand the healthiest, the
smartest, the handsomest boys uh at from
whatever age. It could be as as 6 10 12
and they would call them off to become
either warriors uh which became the
janiseries or the yans which basically
means new soldiers, new warriors because
and they were you converted to Islam and
essentially indoctrinated in jihadist um
you know ideology and then also let and
then it was like a very vicious cycle
because then they would let them loose
again on the Christians their own
forbear their own former relatives and
they would conquer some more and more
children. So they were basically drying
them, bleeding them dry of their best uh
genetics, their own pool for their own
to use them into their own military.
Whenever I think about this and I think
of these people just trying to survive
under the oppression of Muslim
domination and rule and Sharia and to
think that you have a little baby boy,
you've got a couple of little girls, you
have a little baby boy, he gets to be
six or eight years old and the the I
don't know if they were khalifs there or
sultans or or sometimes I get confused
with their no sultans and they come
riding in for their annual or semiannual
or every 3 or four years, whatever it
is. And they have to line up all the
little boys in the village. Every little
boy, no one is exempt. And then they
just go through and you're holding your
breath and some even scarring their
children so that they would not be fit
to serve, naming them, naming them,
breaking an arm or or doing something to
it. But it is a horror. And that was the
Ottomans. Now the Ottomans and here we
are skipping forward. So we got to go
backwards in a minute. But just remember
this. When France and England and other
nations went up against the Germans and
the Ottomans in the first world war and
the Ottoman Empire as well as the German
Empire was broken up. These are those
people. This is right before the League
of Nations. This is uh this is what the
League of Nations came out of this war
and this is where they took these
oppressed lands a
400year suppression. Well, it actually
goes back to Muhammad of course, but
that
particular last Ottoman Empire, the
Ottomans,
um they broke it
up and 99% was given to Muslims. Either
the Turks kept some, a big chunk of it,
too big, and the Arabs got the rest, and
then Israel got
1.2%
12% as I figured it. Just take my word
for it. So, they got 1% of it. This is
the kind of empire that was ruling that
was broken up and divided into states.
So when we have this idea that you get
filled up with that, you know, France
and England came in and took the the
Muslim Middle East, it was peaceful,
everything was hunky dory, everything
was great, and then they just carved it
up all for and of course there's always
ulterior motives as well, but they
carved it all up and gave it to the
Jews, you know, essentially. None of
that is true. They carved up a wicked
wicked empire and ended for a time the
caliphate which was probably one of the
greatest things that happened in
history. Let's go back where let's go to
the battle of tours. I want you to
describe what the battle of tours was.
What was at risk? How did how did it
end? And you know what were the fate of
those who were who were killed?
Sure. Um but but I'll just make one last
comment about the Janisary. Uh so what
you described is true and actually the
sources talk about when they would come
and pick these boys, you know, mothers
would be hysterically crying. Some
fathers would get killed because they
would try to prevent the seizure of
their sons. And now here's the thing. If
you grab an academic book today and you
read about it, there are literally
academic scholars who present this as a
sort of it was a good thing. It was a
scholarship like to Oxford because
because these were poor peasant
Christians and they took their sons and
if you became a janisary you became rich
and powerful and a noble figure in the
Ottoman Empire. So supposedly they
wanted to be recruited and taken away
from their families even though the
sources talk about them crying and
fighting and trying to escape and being
killed. And you never listen to Islamic
sources when you're writing Islamic
history. Now, let that is the rule of
thumb. If you're going to talk about
modern history, news reports, if you're
going to talk about the Ottoman Empire,
anything, you can't use the Islamic
sources. Why?
Because sadly, what I'm telling you,
what I'm telling you if this this these
are Western sources. That's what I'm
saying. No, my point is that the the
Western historians are never going to
report what's actually in the record,
the contemporary record. I mean, when
when you look at these histories, these
histories, many of Muhammad's chronicers
and those of the Khalifs and the
Ottomans and all the rest of them, um,
they had chronicers and they're telling
it from a firsthand eyewitness history
about playing men alive, cutting their
skins off of their entire body alive.
And but we can't but but that never
seems to make it into western histories
of jihad I mean of Islam that that I was
that was my point. So tell me take me to
the battle of Oh go ahead.
No that's why this is what what you're
saying is the reason I wrote sword and
scimitar because it's and I assume you
you know you read it. You said you read
it. So, I'm sure a lot of it was kind of
shocking and surprising because it's so
opposite of what being taught in
schools, but what's being taught in
schools, you know, where's it trace? It
goes back to John Espazito of Georgetown
University and Carrie Armstrong. Okay?
But what I wrote is actually the
sources. It's the Arabic Muslim sources.
It's the Christian chronicles of the
time. And they just they relay that much
different picture. They show you Islam
always behaving like ISIS on steroids
essentially. Um so this is the great
divide unfortunately where a modern
people are subject to these secondary
histories which are essentially what our
children are indoctrinated you know uh
uh what's his name Khaled Rashidi in at
Colombia and so many other of these uh
Middle East studies teachers and and I
you know Edward say he was not Middle
East studies but um it's it's it's
literally propaganda and indoctrination
under the guise of historic scholarship.
And some of it's very thin. I mean, it's
almost comical, laughable, but others
present themselves well as if it's true
history. It is not. And you have to read
like Sword and Scitar or I happen to
have Robert Spencer because I talked to
him for a couple hours the other day. Uh
history uh the history of jihad from
Muhammad to ISIS. I I really wasn't
surprised uh by your book at all because
I know enough of it. Um but I just loved
how you you really laid it out very
systematically and fully and um and and
the breadth of it really really good.
So they conquer how how far did they get
at the beginning? I'm never quite sure
about this. I know they go quickly
across northern Africa. They go into
Spain very quickly and they're
challenging southern France where the
Battle of Tours eventually was in I
think 732. But I I can't quite get my uh
head around how far north did they just
go up to Syria were the Armenians
affected by uh like the second Khalif?
So, you know what I have? I have in my
hand sort of in the scimitar and I'm
going to I have a map in here which I'm
going to try to show. I don't know if
you can see it, but the
map you see all those dark regions are
formerly Christian regions that were
permanently conquered. The gray ones are
Christian regions that were temporarily
conquered like Spain and the Balkans and
all the and the stripes are raids. So if
you can see it's almost like everything
but the center of Europe was one way or
another impacted and affected. All
right. So basically um from the
beginning that we started 634 which is
really the first major battle battle of
Aishnaden until let's say the siege of
Vienna in 1683 almost a thousand years
okay 3/4 of Christendom conquered
everything like I mentioned North Africa
the Middle East Spain portions of France
all the Mediterranean later on Asia
Minor and then all of the Balkans all
the way up until Vienna but also as you
indicated Iceland is being raided
England is being raided Denmark is being
raided for slaves. Okay. Um, so it was
it's just amazing that that was the
reality. And now what historians do and
what the academics do is when they talk
about conflict, it starts with the
colonial era because everything before
that was fine except of course for the
crusades and the crusades are all are
another blot and they're presented in a
vacuum. I have a quote from John
Espazito, the professor at Georgetown,
where he basically says five centuries,
he basically says everything before the
first crusade between Muslims and
Christians was nothing but peace uh and
love. And then the first crusade just
ruined it all and all these evil
Christian Catholics decided to go and
colonize the Middle East. He doesn't
tell you how actually Muslims during
those peaceful centuries conquered
threequarters of the Christian world in
one in one year alone. I often say this
but one belief from Egypt in the year
109 destroyed 30,000 churches okay under
his rule including the holy seleure the
the church that's uh you know built up
top the resurrection site of Christ um
and but they but they won't talk about
that they'll bring it in the con out of
in a vacuum and say oh yeah the first
crusade guys out of the blue they just
decided to go and attack poor Muslims.
And then they fast forward from that to
the colonial era and once again it's
evil Christians going into Muslim lands
doing what they're doing etc. This is a
crime against our country and I don't
use that term uh unintentionally and I
don't think it's an
overstatement. I don't think you can go
to prison for it though I think
that I would like to figure out a way we
could do that and ret retain our first
amendment. But um this is a crime
against America. Most certainly Europe
has lost its mind. I I remember reading
very recently that the
V are being discussed as uh they were
actually Muslims because supposedly on
some Viking wear some artifact that was
found they found what they were going to
interpret as the word Allah in this
needle point kind of stitching on some
Viking gear. It was clearly law. But
even in Norway, even in Viking lands,
they're being told that, you know, of
course, a brand new history. So
there is a connection between the
Vikings and the Muslims. And it's also
unflattering. And a lot of people don't
know this, but the a lot of the Viking
raids, slave raids on other European
nations, England, Ireland, France, etc.
was to enslave and we know they enslaved
a lot of people, but it was specifically
so they can to the Arab caliphates who
preferred white slaves. And we know this
for a fact because if you do look at the
uh the the the golden horde coins that
are found in Viking burials, they're all
Arab coins. So what exactly were Arabs
buying from these Vikings? What
commodity did they have? We know what
they had. They had a lot of white
slaves. Uh so there is that connection.
That's very true. Yes, white slavery was
a booming business. It'd probably be
multi-billion dollars today if you did
the math uh and brought it up to date.
So,
um I am probably f I'm not maybe famous,
but if I were, I would say I'm famous
for having these wide- ranging
conversations. I start off with all
these great intentions, but the side the
side little
trails are so important and maybe
contextually centuries inevitable. Yes.
Yes.
So, the reason I brought up the map is
because recently when I was looking at
Vienna and I was looking at where Islam
had gotten to um I believe at the Battle
of Vienna and here I am skipping ahead
again. Um, I saw that it was closer, if
this was an accurate map, that the
Muslims had uh taken the land closer to
Kiev or Kev than they had even gotten to
Vienna. And I was utterly shocked. I
couldn't believe that it went all the
way up into Ukraine, all the way up
basically a Sunday's stroll from Kief.
That's how bad it was. But let's go back
to the Battle of Tours. No, but this is
you're woken an important point which
I'd actually like to add to, but you
know, a lot of people don't realize even
Russia was conquered and subjugated and
suffered all the same things that we're
discussing, including mass slavery by
Muslims. But this doesn't really come
out amongst historians because they
don't say they're Muslims. They say
they're Mongols or Tatars, the the
Golden Horn, which was a Mongolian um
empire. But if you look at it, it was
actually a Muslim empire as well. And if
you look at the sources, you realize
that those Mongols were again citing the
Quran, citing the jihadist ideology,
citing everything that we're talking
about in their enslavement and
subjugation of the Russians. So, you
know, it's called the, you know, the
Tatar yoke often, but again, it's part
of this long war of Islam on prison. And
people again, they'll realize that
Russia also suffered it for centuries.
That's so true. And I I have not read uh
that much about that. And I just have
that cursory understanding that they
went up into Russia. But when I think
about how grand and wide and and deep
this this threat to the West was, and
we're going to get to the founding
fathers a little bit later, if we still
have time, because I want to do a little
parallel um from the 1600s on with our
with America, but it's so tragic.
most most
empires well I like to say that the
history of the world is a history of
empire you cannot tell the story of the
world without empire and slavery and so
that means it goes back very very far
and when you look at Babylonia for
Assyria the Hittites I mean you could
just we're not even going to go there of
course that you know that was the time
of uh the Torah and the prophets and
Israel. All of those were eastern,
Middle Eastern, brownskinned, if you
want to say that, empires, the Persians,
the Mes, the Alam, all that. It wasn't
until Greeks in Rome, Mediterraneans, of
course, did they ever get to the
Vatican? Because I my understanding was
that they got to the Vatican and that
they uh ripped up some bones of perhaps
St. Peter, St. Paul, but then someone I
was speaking to the other day was
saying, "Oh, no, no, they never got went
into Italy." And I thought, "Okay, I
need to get that answered." Tell me,
Raymond, did they go into Well, they
most they most certainly invaded and
terrorized Italy. And one of the most
famous was uh the city of Toronto. Um,
and this is I think I want to say in
1480 uh the Ottomans, the Turks invaded
it and they ritually
um savagely killed the Christians there.
They gave them the option to convert or
not. And they I think they I have it in
my book. It's in sort of simar. I
discussed it at length, but basically
they tortured and beheaded and killed
something like a thousand Christians and
they took their archbishop and sawed him
in half. And until now, if you go to the
Cathedral of a Toronto, they you can
look it up online, they have they have
their skulls in glass cases because
they're the martyrs of a Toronto. Um so
that's just one attack on Italy. As far
as Rome and the Vatican, etc. Yeah,
actually Muslims did attack it. It's a
very little known um anecdote which was
in the mid 9th century. I want to say
around 856. I think that's a small
little thing. I mean to me I know it's
not when they take Jerusalem. By the
way, we've been talking about
Christendom. And I do want to uh um
point out that um it's just an oversight
that we're not saying it's also was home
of the Jews. I mean in the the Arabian
Peninsula
um obviously uh if if uh if the Muslims
were slaughtering the Jews, the Jews
were there first because Islam came
after. There was uh many many Jews in
Yemen and of course um all over the
Middle East, Babylon, you know, now
Iraq, uh Persia of course, that's where
Daniel and Esther and all the rest ended
up. So, but just not as great numbers
were the Jews. So, it was primarily
Christian, but the numbers were not as
great. So I didn't want to uh say that
you know I don't think you know when
they when they conquer invade subject
um Judea or the or Judah and Judea
depending on how you want to look at it
um and and
Jerusalem and when they do the same to
Rome and I'm not Catholic though my
mother said because I was born Catholic
I'm always Catholic so maybe I
Just so note, are you Catholic or
Orthodox or I get a feeling from
Orthodox? I figured you were Orthodox.
Anyway,
um I think taking Rome and the fact
don't doesn't Muhammad and his
followers, don't they call like the West
Rome? I mean, isn't there a word that
they use in Arabic?
No. Yeah. Rome. They refer in the early
Arabic sources uh usually they're
talking about what now modern historians
call Byzantian the eastern Roman Empire
but it was known to the Arabs because it
was Rome and so they refer to it as Rome
and yeah and often times it gets
conflated with much of the west but then
by the time the the France the the first
crusade comes then the main word becomes
from France maybe you even know the word
which still exists till They if you say
someone is a frugi means he's
westernized but it comes from
interesting interesting so
the the idea that um I I hear Muslims
all the time now say you know uh that
one of the top priorities in the jihad
against the west is to take Rome and put
a flag of the caliphate over the
Vatican.
I don't think that the modern I I'm
sorry. I don't I don't think that the
current pope really considers that a
threat.
No, this has been from the very
beginning. It goes back to Muhammad and
he wanted to see the conquest of Rome
which to him in his time was
Constantinople. Constantinople. Yeah.
Okay. And um so that was one of the
longest um you know the goals of every
jihadist. And they find and they
attacked it right before years. Yeah.
Yeah. They started attacking it in the
650s soon after Muhammad's uh you know
death and it was by the cockp yeah yeah
almost thousand years in 1453 but then
they also wanted Rome because uh by 1453
Rome now is is a grown power it wasn't
it was you know under barbarian rule the
time of Muhammad that's why they looked
at Constantinople but they also wanted
the reason they wanted Vienna too was it
was the seat of the Holy Roman Empire so
a lot of the cities that they really
focused on was for the religious
symbolic elements because it was seen as
the heart of Christendom and of course
Islam must conquer it and break the
cross and subjugate it. So until now
they you know you have Muslims and ISIS
and so forth clamoring about how they
need to conquer Rome and uh again that
goes all the way back to the beginning
that sort of idea.
You know I would like to take another
divergence. I may have to have you back
to actually do the little uh sword and
scimitar step through each battle
because it is a military history and
we're we're we're not really uh staying
on that timeline. But whatever, we're
having fun. I'm having fun. Um I want to
talk about the Muslim
lake, the Mediterranean.
And when I read, oh my gosh, Muhammad
and Charlemagne or there's a couple of
books, uh, a Frenchman wrote it very
small. Henry Pin. Yeah, Pere.
Yeah, Henry Pin. Henry or I I think of
him as Henri. But
anyway, I I thought that was one of the
most enlightening things I ever learned.
And to me, it has to do with one
rewriting of history. And I'm going to
let you tell it. Rewriting of history,
cultural appropriation, appropriation of
the of the great heights of art and
intellect and medicine and science uh by
Islam which is a normalized thing. also
their architecture taking the the you
know when they're not burning a thousand
churches they're converting basilas and
cathedrals into uh churches and then
saying look at our I mean into mosques
and saying look at our gorgeous
architecture.
But that changed that was one of those
paradigm shifts that utterly changed my
view of history that that when think
about well no I'm going to tell you tell
us about looking at the Mediterranean
pre-Islam and post Islam and what it
ended up uh doing to Christendom and the
dark ages and all that stuff. Yeah,
sure. So, and this goes back to the
Henry Pin thesis. Um, he came up with
the idea in the 1800s. Um, this is a
still at the time when historians will
talk about a dark age descending on
Europe. And generally it starts, they
give different dates, but maybe 700 till
900 or,000. And um his point which is a
very salient and accurate point is
really it's the Islamic conquest that
I've been discussing we've been
discussing that literally led to this
dark age specifically by the
appropriation of what was once known as
the Roman lake the Mediterranean which
uh was the highway for all those
countries. This is why Egypt and Rome
and Spain and um you know Asia Minor and
the Holy Land were all interconnected as
one as part of the Roman Empire. And um
with the Islamic conquest that we were
discussing in the 7th century, it
completely severed it because now the
southern part was all conquered and all
Islamized and all you had was the north
which as I mentioned earlier was
actually the poorer, more impoverished
and uh less developed region of the
Christian world. And so for as one
example um papyrus ceased to be imported
from Egypt to Europe therefore literacy
rates dramatically fell. That's one
example that someone like PN refers to.
You know, his book is called Charlemagne
and Muhammad and he makes the famous lie
where without a Muhammad there would be
no Charlemagne because all the
development that happened in Western
Europe and the rise of Charlemagne, the
Holy Roman Empire was a reaction to what
Islam had been doing. And so really the
dark ages once again it's a it's a
reflection of what Islam did. Al this is
also the time when the Viking agings are
attacking and other nomadic tribes from
the east are are sweeping in but it's
really the Islamic conquest that had the
most um uh impact on it. As far as the
other point, I think you're referring
to, you know, a lot of the golden age
that's often allotted to Islamic
civilization, which was really an
appropriation of the civilizations that
they had conquered. And this is true as
well. If you look at a lot of the the
thinkers and the philosophers amongst
the Muslims that always heralded as
great thinkers, etc., you find that
they're either recent converts to Islam
who were Christians or and Muslims and
Jews almost all or I'm sorry yeah
Christians or Jews um who who had been
just recently converted or were their
their parents you know for for you know
just for practical reasons but they
still brought the sort of Christian
Jewish background heritage and knowledge
and so forth um and and and again it's
also important one of the biggest lines
here again is how history is so
distorted. One of the biggest lines is
that the Muslims brought saved Aristotle
and brought back to Europe. So Europe
owes Muslim stance. But what they don't
tell you is it's the Muslims attack on
Europe that created this discontinuity
that caused Europe to lose Aristotle in
the first place based on what I said,
this discontinuity through the
Mediterranean. So if it wasn't for the
Muslims, uh Europe would have never lost
Aristotle or anyone else to start with.
We didn't they didn't need the Arabic
translations from the original Greek.
You know what it's like. Exactly. And by
the way, I I I read the book u so many
years ago, I can't I can barely remember
it. How the Irish save civilization. So,
um, so there's two competing theories
there, but it's almost like this a great
analogy of, um,
Muslims move into the West, go into
Europe, and when they're in the foreign
land, the Christian lands, they're more
radicalized because they are at war as
opposed to um, in in Middle Eastern and
North Africa land uh, uh, nations. um
you know they own it and they've got a
dict a dictator or a hardcore monarch
over and above them. So there's no no
place for jihad and radicalization
um there or or or there's much less
obviously there's tons of violence
against Muslim against Muslim but you
move into the west and you're at war
whether it's violence whether it's birth
whether you know demographics etc. You
are at war. You move in intentionally in
massive numbers into a place that you
say is filled with infidels and
everything about it is wicked and sinful
and then you
claim Islamophobia. You accuse everyone
of Islamophobia. So you caused the
problem because if you stayed in Muslim
lands under Sharia with Muslim monarchs
and Muslim presidents and you could live
and everybody's wearing nikab and all
the rest, you'd have nothing to be upset
about. You move to the place where you
can be the belligerent and then you call
them Islamophobes. And so what you're
saying here is the Muslim um jihad holy
war. This is their holy
war. Um takes over the Roman lake, makes
it a Muslim lake and this grand
um this grand sea of commerce of
exchange of culture and religion and
trade and wealth. And I mean just
imagine the
Anian prior to Islam and all paper
unless it was leather. Okay. If you have
I don't why I'm looking for a
leather B. I don't have um I'm trying to
think of like a skin where the paper is
made out of skin.
Anyway, was the cheap way to make paper.
It was all made out of papyrus. Europe
was
absolutely literate and obviously what
did the Apostle Paul write on
originally? A lot of it was papyrus and
then later of course on leather. But
when if you if if literally in the
United States
today, well, we have computers. Forget
computers. In the
1940s, if all paper dried up and not one
piece of paper could be found in all of
our
nation, what would happen to literacy at
that time? That's one just one of the
effects, the belligerance and the
wararmongering of Islam. And then was
didn't he also speak Henri about how
all of the populations that lived on
those beautiful coastlines. I'm thinking
Capri, you know, it's so beautiful that
they moved far from the
coastlands. So all of their lands, their
farms, their their history, their
heritage, you know, family farms and
their villages emptied out because and
and or those who were left were
impoverished because one, they would
either be enslaved by raiders and well,
they just didn't want to be the victims
of of raiding.
Yeah. This is the start of feudalism. So
all the people who lived on the coasts,
if they stayed there, Muslim raiders and
enslavers would come and get them. So
they started gravitating to the powerful
nobles and they became this is the
beginning ofism. Yeah. For protection
and they worked on their land because
the alternative was to continue living
near the coast and
become a slave for the Muslims.
Yeah. You know it changes so much. Again
I'm going to say it's a crime because
the reality is that this is not really
complicated history. There are a lot of
complicated histories like uh the
Israeli Arab uh conflict. There's so
many tens of thousands of details you
have to know to really understand it
well. But this is really simple. This is
broad strokes and you understand holy
war, jihad, Sharia, uh the caliphate. Um
it it doesn't I mean a semester and you
could be an expert if you really studied
it. So, oh by the way, why didn't you
mention
Indians? Um, of course, at one point
there was no Pakistan and Bangladesh. Of
course, India in at least the modern
world included all of what is Pakistan
today and all of what is Bangladesh
today, of course. And so that was that
was changed in 1947 and then 71 for
Bangladesh. But before
that, Islam kept moving through
Persia, through Afghanistan. I don't
know what that was called. That
Afghanistan was Buddhist, which shocked
me. Um, and then in into India and they
ended up
killing millions. I've read some of the
historical accounts. Millions upon
millions upon millions of Indians. You
know, I mean,
there's so many people in India. Imagine
how many people would be be there now.
You say hundreds of millions which is so
mindboggling to even you know consider
but yeah so the stretch of it we're
talking Morocco and Spain we're talking
India obviously most of the east at the
very beginning all the way up as far as
you know they could go. I still don't
know if uh the Armenians were affected
um and into France. And so let's talk
about the
um about tours. I I heard a comment that
it wasn't really that big of a deal.
Wasn't that important? I'm thinking
really you don't think the battle of
tours was important?
So for the longest time from the time of
the battle of tourists because we have
we are contemporary chronicles it was
seen as a watershed moment because uh
Islam and most people don't realize
that. So while Muslims were coming in
through Spain and attacking France and
had reached Tours in the eastern part of
the empire uh they were actually this
was the same time they were attacking
Constantinople and trying to break
through the east. So it was almost like
a pinchment um and they would meet in
the middle. So, so anyway, to most
historians up until maybe a century ago,
it was a decisive moment. And had had
had the Franks lost at the battle of
Torres, it could very well be, I think
Edward Gibbon famously said that the
Quran would now be recited in Oxford.
And of course, it is now being recited
in Oxford. But under There you go. But
of course, there would not have been an
Oxford if they had conquered Europe that
early.
there. Yep. We would be living in a
dystopian nightmare, right?
Oh my gosh. And now they um now they
downplay
was Charles Martell. I I always think
Brandy when I that name it's just
immediately I think of some cognac or
brandy.
Charles Martell which means the hammer.
uh he got the nickname Mr. because he
actually back then the kings and or the
leaders would actually be in the deep in
the the fight fighting. So he was
actually right there fighting alongside
his men and it's very picturesically
described in the Chronicles um with him
smiting his foes with his hammer. Um but
anyway, it's him against the Muslims but
yeah under the leadership of Yeah. under
the leadership of Abdul
Rahman, one of many of them. Um, but a
lot of it was Berbers. So, it's ironic
because the Berbers in the decades
before the battle of Tours were
resisting Islam in North Africa and
constantly fighting it and they were
amongst the most who were enslaved uh
under Islam. But then they reached a
point where, you know, if you can't beat
them, join them. And they became the
greatest jihadis, the par excellence,
and they're the ones who essentially
conquered um uh Spain. And most of the
troops who fought under Arab leadership
were Berbers who were Muslims uh at the
battle of Tours. And um yeah so but
you're right nowadays as usual they try
to minimize it. They try to cut off the
religious element. Oh there was just two
waring tribes some Franks and some Moors
and there was no religious. But again if
you look at the sources um it does come
out as a religious conflict. And it's
true. Muslims don't talk too much about
it. It's known in Islamic history. I
think it's known as the as the battle of
the pavement, which is a reference to
floors being so bloody. But it's also
known that Muslims and other people
don't exactly dwell on their losses and
make it into a big story. They usually
more heographically dwell and obsess
over their victories, okay? Such as the
battle of Garmoot. So that makes sense
as well. But anyway, it's part of the
modern western trend to minimize the
conflict and to now they talk about it
as just a raid, but that's not what the
sources says.
And you know what what's important to me
of course we all make our judgments what
is important to fix in our mind is that
they had already conquered you know I
don't know 2/3 about at this time I
don't know 7:32 but they had already
spanned you know this great uh width of
the world and they were going to now
think about it you go to France to visit
and this
was a battle battle right in like if you
have France north to south tours is
right in the middle of the north to
south and it's on the western side
there's a battle there if they had lost
France which I have problems with French
people but you know what they deserve to
be French right they to stay French
um fought off Islam and that's where the
tide for a while started to shift um had
they already taken all of Spain or ex
except for like just that little western
section up at the top, you know. Yeah.
This is a this is a tight
shift that now Islam is stopped and it
can't go further into the west and it is
a mental there's a a victory. This is a
good thing to have victory.
When we're looking at Europe, the small
victories or like Poland standing firm
or Donald Trump, you know, uh winning
these victories are moral um they they
they get they reignite hope. We always
have hope in the Lord, but they reignite
temporal hope that yes, maybe things
will turn back and truth and justice and
righteousness will prevail for a time.
Tell me how you what you would say to
Western leaders, legislators,
presidents, prime ministers about how
jihad of the last 14 years, 100 years
should inform how we think of the of
immigration,
immigration and of
um how we should order our societies
today.
you know in a word I would just use the
word continuity and by that all I mean
is the current paradigm that policy
makers and what whoever powers that be
and um uh when they talk about the
question of Islam the paradigm they use
completely fake one which is Islam means
peace and if anything it's the
westerners who always started
hostilities etc. If you understand the
history that we're talking about, it's
one of continuity because from the very
beginning all the way until the modern
era, it's it's Muslim hostility and
violence and preaching hatred based on
Islamic teaching etc. against the caffer
or infidel. Okay. Now, if you're a
policy maker or anyone in the west who
wants to understand how to deal with
Islam, once you understand that that is
the history and it's been unwavering and
manifested itself through different
peoples and nations, that's why the
Arabs did what they did, the Turks did
what they did, the Mongols did what they
did. It was all under the same
imperatives, um the same Islamic
teaching. Um well, then you start
understanding what you're seeing today.
So if you look at Europe then you see
migrant this migrant issue and wherever
there's large Muslim populations you
have a lot of problems you have
criminality you have rape you have
grooming gangs with England you have
problems in Sweden you have problems in
Germany Austria that's France okay so
there's a reason for that but if you
can't understand the first premise which
is that's the way it's always been based
on Islamic teaching then you're always
going to look for some other excuse
you're going to say this is racism This
is Muslim grievances. This is whatever
they're disenfranchised. Well, no,
because it was always the case. Even
when Islam was superior and way more
powerful than Europe, that's how it was.
So, it just you need a paradigm shift
and a corrective based on the accurate
history of Islam. We should be the West.
Well, Raymond, it's been a pleasure
having you. Real fun. Thank you for
joining me and I hope I can have you
again later and we can talk more about
history and
Islam. My pleasure, Elizabeth. Thanks
for having me. He was fun.